here are this week's top movies hey  Paris I college' stasis her most  fearsome and personal haunting yet in  insidious the last key the life of an  acclaimed dressmaker is disrupted when  he falls for a young strong-willed woman  and phantom threat you're not cursed  your love by me stop playing this game  I'll be hosting a game in this suite  every Tuesday night the first buy-in  250,000 a highly accomplished woman is  targeted by the FBI in Molly's case when  we saw it  athletes bitten as that's just the tip  of the iceberg see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fantasy  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]